well
mari thank you so much for joining us
can you tell me the story of how you two
met
well um my parents every summer would
uh go to the lake in in canada
and the place was called turkey point
which is on lake erie
and uh just have a nice summer holiday
there water skiing
swimming you know sunbathing this was
back in the 60s
and i was sitting on the pier with a few
girlfriends and
telling them my story you know and then
all of a sudden i looked up
and i saw this figure in the distance
coming
onto the pier now we're all dressed in
bathing suits and swimwear we're
swimming and this that and the other
and here he comes dark trousers in fact
they were black
white shirt and a tie and
a straw kind of a panama hat
and you know so he was very he stood out
yeah
and uh so i invited him to come and sit
down and
so he continued to talk and we just
talked and talked and talked and then
later moved
to the beach and um i think the next
time i saw him he was talking to another
girl and i thought yeah you know man
i know i was okay okay next
well about six months later i receive a
letter
and it's a letter from roger and then we
start this lovely correspondence and we
just start writing you know in those
days
you just wrote everything and uh
and then the next summer he was coming
up again
he was on his way to alaska and um
he says i would like to come by and see
you and i said well i'll be in the same
place that i met you last year
and so when we when he came up this time
for some reason roger reached for my
hand and i reached for his
and man that was it it was like
love and for first touch that was love
it was just like a silence you know and
oh my gosh and we didn't even look at
each other
it was just oh my goodness what happened
here and i was the type of person i
never wanted to get married not
way way way down the road never have any
children
and i wanted to see the world first and
then do all that
you know and um but that was it that was
love
and you've been together ever since yeah
well
the thing is about the love the the two
you have for each other
is they had to persevere through quite a
heck of a journey
so how did roger's
drug smuggling change the nature of your
love
and your relationship well lex that
remained steadfast it uh
it endured and um since roger's been
home i think we've rekindled
the love that we had when we first met
yeah what
but but i think my faith
um you know my faith my steadf fast
faith and also the fact that roger and i
communicated we wrote letters you know
he
he never complained i know there were
the children there he never had
mistreated me i loved this guy
and we had a lot of experiences it was
just
even though good looking charismatic
he's pretty you know yeah and he's
advent
he was adventurous you know and
would you say that again but um
yes it was just i know i you know i
missed him physically but
he was just we were just so strong in
spirit
you know and um we could talk to one
another
yep well what was it like
uh roger when you're a free man
seeing mari for the first time in person
again i uh i cried for three days
everything i'd look at a picture of her
i came home and
uh there's she prepared a meal for me
and uh it was the old oak table that i'd
redone and the chairs the same one and
the green
placemats in the same china that we had
in the same silverware
and it just just all of it just brought
back the same paintings on the wall
it was like unbelievable after 35 years
she had all my clothes cleaned and my
shoes shining and
i put the shoes on and i walked out on
the strings on this
and the soles came off but the shirts
and all fit perfect and everything so
it's just wonderful
and just just to see her and then just
to think about see her picture of her
50th birthday or her 60th birthday or
her 70th birthday
i wasn't there in the picture of her and
with the children it just
it was heartbreaking and about the third
day i thought man up philly i mean
you've got to so uh i got over and quick
quit
with the uh quit the tears but it was it
was
it was everything was just pulsating
with life it was just
unbelievable to get out of that place it
really was
is there uh do you regret
the the the drug smuggling that took uh
you away from the woman you love oh yes
100 just you know
i wouldn't have done it again if you
don't think you're going to get caught
and uh it's just no it's just i did it
for money and i had everything in the
world i wanted before i did that
so the adventure i mean it was one heck
of an adventure for the two of you
for the both of you yes were you able to
enjoy it or
was it always danger was was was it
always something that threatened
your relationship your love your family
are we able to enjoy the adventure of it
you know we all die
life is short and to live that kind of
adventure
well whenever i did the first loot i'm
about ten thousand dollars
and that was just about that was just
about two years pay on the fire
department take home
and i broke that home and i put my hand
over my mouth i said
she took it over there i can't believe
that's
my what in the world but i just said
let's go have
dinner and so we went to the restaurant
that we would norm
we would go to you know and he said
don't you dare look on the right hand
side of the of the menu he said just
order anything you want
and it was just as we were in the
restaurant you know it was just we were
giddy about it
yeah i was giddy about it and um
were you afraid that i mean did you
think about the
fact that it's illegal and uh roger
gonna
end up in in prison oh yes
did you guys talk about it well i just
i kind of thought i'd bulletproof i mean
they didn't catch you i thought if they
didn't catch you you was all right it
was hard to get you
hard to catch you in in the air yeah so
you never thought hard to catch in there
i didn't know that if your friend told
on you five years later you'd still go
to
right that was a problem i didn't know
that did you did you guys ever talk
about walking away
i asked roger to walk to walk away and
he says
i can't marry just now you know and then
of course the
the amount of people that he began to
support
the family and the gifts and the deals
the deals yes the deals big ones
yes and then you always want to do what
do you do with the money
you know so you want to i guess you
clean it up or you want to invest in a
in an enterprise or in a business
well it just doesn't work they know the
source of it and they take it and run
every one of them yep yeah but he was
very
generous extremely generous and
benevolent
and and when i started i i uh i would
ask about i went to a lawyer and
a good good people a number of people in
in california that time wanted to
legalize marijuana
back 1973. and i went to a lawyer and i
said
mr lawyer i put a hundred dollars on
today what what would they do if they
caught me
bringing marijuana across the board he
said uh if you have a criminal record i
said no
i've never had a speeding ticket not
nothing nothing not even a traffic
ticket
i said he said he worked for the fire
department that's what i'm saying i said
yes sir
he said you'll get probation the worst
you'll do is you'll get
one year and you've spent four four
months raking leaves on a military base
so my mother my father died some years
before and my brother mother and baby
sister came out and
i took him down to disneyland and she
said what you doing boy
i said i'm hauling pot mom she said how
much you making i said making forty
thousand dollars any day i want to go
and she said what they do if they catch
and i told her what the lawyer said
four months at the most reckon leaves
that's what do you think she said do you
need a co-pilot son
yeah money is money yeah
it's um so
your relationship persevered through
some
some big challenges is there advice you
can give about
what makes for a successful relationship
oh well you know i think the initial
igniting meeting someone you know that
that's the love
that's it and that that that little fire
just that fire just keeps burning and
burning and burning
you can't put it out no matter what it's
the
the love fire but it gets difficult
as far as it's funny the love fire so
you're saying the love fires all it
takes to to persevere through the
difficulty well
no i well that's a huge part of it
and also i contribute my my individual
situation
to uh in order to endure what the prison
years is my faith
faith in god yes and
friends who were unconditionally still
loved me no matter what
yes so she had love
around you i did and my children
they you know and that was a real
purpose
to guide them and to love them and to
help them
become citizens
what about you roger what advice would
you give
i just don't know how to do it but i do
know that you have to work on a
relationship
and laura and i have had problems i mean
we good really you guys are getting
fights
oh yeah oh yes
but not they don't let them laugh long
yeah you know but
certainly we are so dead
yeah like little stuff little stuff yeah
and uh it might be big but i usually
winter over you know
but it's but anyhow i just feel like
mario was always
there it was like she was in my anchor
yeah i was coming home
i was always coming home to her and the
children and you can see throughout my
life
i'm working on getting there are you
afraid for his life
by the way oh yes oh yeah there are
times
yeah but you know i had some i had faith
in him he was an
excellent pilot for example i always
said roger if the ship's going down
i'm jumping in the lifeboat with you
because i know we're going to get to
shore
you will save us and so i had that i
have that faith in him you know i mean
he's he's a man but yet he's the one you
want to get into the lifeboat with
definitely but then there is uh
you know pablo escobar one of the most
dangerous humans in history
plus the us government
very difficult uh very difficult to get
away
in terms of your faith um how has
your faith helped you to be the woman
you are in this relationship
in in in seeing love the way you see it
well i think my faith gives me hope i
have lots of
hope it helps me to
dwell on the good side you know when i
ever i
meet someone and there's some negative
i try to see why they are like that or
what's the source of all that
and i try to pull out the good i really
do
not that i'm a goody goody but that's
what your faith does you know you
see them as god sees us you know
how has he changed over the years roger
yeah he's still the same
actually i like him better now
he's a little calmer yeah he knows crazy
oh yes
and happy to be you know at home or
he'll say
mari i am just so happy to be with you
here in this condominium
i'm content because i used to call him
my homing pigeon you know i just have to
let him fly i couldn't
no he has to fly but he always came home
you